Welcome, everybody, to another Zoom call. It is
February 11th,
2026, and
Reminder to check the member site for everything, announcements and such, and anything else that's going on.
I'm continually adding more information to the member site and more videos to the member site, so make sure you
recheck things as you go.
And
we did have somebody saying that they're having difficulty with their browser. I think they're using brave as a browser to get
questions submitted and
I do realize that can be a problem with different browsers. So if you do have trouble, if it's not allowing you to submit your questions
then feel free to email your questions to info at
cutters.clinic.info and cutters.clinic make sure you spell it C-O-N-N-E-R-S,
clinic.com, and you can email the questions. And to me, that's just fine.
It isn't any harder to copy and paste a question from an email, and it is from that form. So that's no problem.
For years, when we before we had the member site, how long have we had the member site? Two years, no.
For years, you know, all the years before that, people emailed the questions in.
To get out of the Zoom call.
And then questions that they had during the Zoom call, they would verbalize them.
And again, I mentioned that it was about four years ago or something, somebody chatted in.
First time somebody chatted a question in and then ever since then, everybody just chatted their questions in.
So you could feel free to chat them in. If you have questions as we go through this,
that's just fine if you feel more comfortable with that.
But again, if you want to verbalize your question, I think that's great too.
Just unmute yourself. So whatever works doesn't make any difference.
First question.
What is the best way to block EMFs in your home?
Well, the best way is to put your entire house in a Faraday cage.
But that's not really reasonable cost-wise. So it's impossible. That's a joke.
So the truth is you really can't block the EMFs in your home.
So you have to try to mitigate it as well.
And how do you mitigate EMFs in your home? You look at where are the greatest amount of
negative high frequency, electromagnetic frequencies coming from.
The number one thing would be cell towers near your home.
If you live right outside your door is a 5G cell tower.
You are hit with a ton of EMFs. That could be highly dangerous.
If I was in the city, let's say in a large city living in an apartment in a large city
and there was a big EMF or there was a big cell tower right nearby home.
And of course, all of them are 5G now.
Honestly, I would move. I would just move. I would not want to be near that.
Because it can be so detrimental in so many things with your health, not just causing cancer,
but it can affect so many things that have just not been researched or never will be researched.
But okay, so everybody's near a 5G tower near enough for you to get a signal.
So what do you do? Well, you can only do so much.
So then you go, okay, not moving. You know, the 5G tower that I know,
that I'm near is about a mile away. What are the next things that are causing the most EMF
radiation in my body? Well, our Wi-Fi probably is the next thing.
So turning your Wi-Fi off at night before you go to bed, you don't need your Wi-Fi on while you're
in bed. Many times you don't need your Wi-Fi on, but maybe an hour a day or I don't know. So you
can just have your Wi-Fi on one of those power strips where you can just turn it off and turn it back on.
I mean, usually it takes a minute for it to turn back on. So turning off your Wi-Fi,
when you're not using it, that would be a real good solution to help minimize, of course,
again, you're never bringing this down to zero. So minimize EMFs. What's another source of EMFs
in your house? Well, your cell phone, your cell phone is high about of EMFs. Even if it's all off,
you're still getting EMFs from your cell phone because there's still communication that's going
through your cell phone. Now, I know I think if you powered it off completely, it's probably pretty
low, but you can't do that. You know, somebody might want to try to get hold of you. So you can't do
that. We're so dependent upon our cell phones, but definitely not using your cell phone up to your head,
using your cell phone. When you are communicating, make it a call, you're having a speaker phone,
or you have a wired connection, you know, to a phone and a wired headphone or use those EMF
reducing headphones. Something like that, you're trying to mitigate it. Never charge your cell phone
right next to your band to keep it away from you at night, you don't need it right next to you. You
can put it in the bathroom, turn your rigor up, if somebody's trying to call you in the middle of
that, you'll still hear it, things like that. You're trying to mitigate things. And then you get dirty
electricity from your own house wiring, and there's ways through that static brand to help mitigate the
dirty electricity. We have the whole house static EMF mitigator on our panel, our electrical panel. We
had to have an electrician put that in, but you can get the plugins at the office. We have the plugins.
So those are some of the only things you can do. I mean, otherwise, you know,
there, we live in a world that there's EMF going through us all the time. That's why you have
reception on your telephone. So there's, you just do the best you can, and you leave the results to
God like everything else. So, you know, become crazy about this stuff. You have to know that
you're protected. If you're doing the best you can, within reason, you know, God is going to protect
you. You have to disbelieve that. Okay, next question. I saw your post on turkey tail mushrooms. Do
you have that available to add to our protocol? It is one of the six mushrooms in rice coffee. So
rice coffee is a brand of coffee that is a mushroom coffee. Would you recommend using that to get the
turkey tail? So rice coffee has like six different mushrooms in the coffee, and you're putting a
table spoon in your coffee as a instant coffee, and it is organic. So I you can certainly use that.
But remember, if I did your cheek swab in it, didn't say you needed to use turkey tail mushrooms,
then you don't need it. But if you feel land that you want to add turkey tail mushrooms to your
protocol, you could use rice coffee. We have our we have our turkey tail complete product, our
cutters clinic, turkey tail product also. Also another good brand is the host defense turkey tail
product. Those are the two good products that we have in the store that I like the best.
But you could use rice coffee if you like that. That's fine too.
There really isn't a downside to adding mushrooms to anybody's protocol. So
the only
caveat to that would be if you have brain cancer, you don't want to add lions made. But
short of you know, having brain cancer, there really isn't any negatives to adding any
in the mushrooms to your protocol, any of the mushrooms. So yeah, that would be just fine.
Next question. What do you think about adding hydrogen water to my cancer protocol? Do you know
if this is a good brand and the person I think shared a link that I did that I'm not aware of. So
I don't know if that was a good brand. Now hydrogen water, I have people have asked this question.
Somebody asked this question just recently. I don't think there's any downside to adding hydrogen water
I will say that there's been some data on hydrogen water that it can function as an anti-oxidant
but I'm not sure that that's correct data. All that I've seen about hydrogen water to be
has benefits. It increases the oxygenation of the water. There is a bottle out there. I think it's
W-E-I. If you just search W-E-I hydrogen water, I think you'll come to their website. A doctor
who used to work for me, some of you might remember her Dr. Kelly Holderman. I have some of her videos
still on our site somewhere. She used to work for me for a number of years. This was a number of years
ago. Gosh, it's been like maybe six years since she worked for me. But I still have good
relationship with her and such. She became the doctor that was for that brand, W-E-I hydrogen water.
She was a representative of theirs. She was kind of the face of the company. I don't know if she
still is. I haven't talked her for about a year or so. But I researched it at the time and it seemed
like a good company. It seems like an inexpensive way overall if you're going to stick with
using hydrogen water to use it because you buy the bottle. It basically is making the hydrogen water
by electrolysis of the water. The bottle itself, you have to charge with a USB port like every five days
or something and you just fill it up with water and you turn it on and it electrolyzes the water
to split the hydrogen and oxygen molecule so it helps to oxygenate the water and you get hydrogen
from the water enough just to H2O as a combined molecule so it has different benefits to your body.
Now the bottle was like I don't 250 bucks or something like that. That's a lot of money. But if
you're going to get the hydrogen tablets to make hydrogen water, that's the other option as you
put these hydrogen tablets in a bottle of water and you shake it and let it sit for a minute or
something and then you drink it. That adds up to, I mean obviously that's a lot plus expensive but when
you add that up you could be spending $30 a month or that. So it seems like if you're going to make a
long-term commitment to hydrogen water getting that wee bottle WEI might be a good idea. But if you
just want to try it, we have the H2 tablets you could purchase on our store. I don't remember how
much they are but it seems like they're like a dollar a tablet or something like that so you'll spend
$30 a month if you're just doing one model of it every day. So I don't make anything off the WEI
product. You have to go to their website and stuff and look that up. But there's something to look at.
I don't see it as a downside. I don't see it as a necessity though either. I do know that there
I do think that the reason why people have asked this question in recent days is because there's just
there's a lot of influencers on Instagram and Facebook. I just saw a doctor Guthrie and about
hydrogen water. Okay so just remember a lot of the influencers will push things because they're selling
something and you know they have no downside to telling people to purchase something because they're
not in practice anymore and you can't be in trouble for making recommendations that are unworthy.
So just keep that in mind. Many things are overhyped, oversold out there in the influencer,
Instagram, Facebook, TikTok world. So just keep that in mind. And keep that in mind even when you
see a video of mine, like the question before on turkey tail, that's a great that's a great product.
I love turkey tail, but it doesn't mean everybody needs it. You know because you could watch a whole
bunch of videos of mine and like, oh I need to take this. I need to take this. I need to take this.
No, I'm just talking about the wonderful thing about IP6. It's a great product, etc. But it's not
for everybody. That's why we do the cheek swab test or the ones you'll be taking a hundred different
things. So you read my book. I probably talk about a hundred different nutraceuticals for cancer.
Are we going to take all those? No, of course we're not. That's why we do the cheek swab test so you
don't have to take all those. But of course, if you're thinking about something and you're praying,
about something that God puts something on your heart, you really feel led that you should do that
than my all means, you know, I asked the question first so that you're not taking something that some
influencers led you down a path that is wrong. But you know, my all means, if you feel led to do
something, then go ahead and do it. But you still want you doing so much that it can harm you
because you remember too much of a good thing can be a bad thing. So just keep that in mind.
Next question. Could I start SEAC-T? Thoughts on it? Is it good brand?
GenuineSEAC.com. I see you sell SEAC extract. Is that a better or easier option? Well,
I'm not saying that our SEAC is better than another SEAC. You know, I did, you know, I did scope out
a lot of different SEAC products before I settled on the one that we use. I do think that the R's
is one of the better ones, though there are maybe other ones that are just as good.
So, but back to should I. So could I start taking SEAC? Yeah, you can. Should you? That's another
question. So we'll go back to the should I take everything that I hear about? No, you should
it. Could you? Yes, you could. Could you overdo it and be taking too many things? Yes, you could.
So just keep that in mind again, like the last question. Make sure that you just
pray about your decisions so that you aren't being influenced by anybody like, you know, your friend,
you know, emailing you saying, you should really take this. This cured my friend or whatever.
You know, just keep that in mind. So make sure you bane everything in prayer. Don't be
influenced in the wrong way to be taking too many things because that can hurt your liver as well.
I consider waiting to start chemotherapy. I asked my ecologist if she could order a CT scan in a
month or two to see if there are any changes either way. I've not heard her answer yet. My question
for you is, is it unrealistic to expect this protocol to show some improvement in one or two months?
I know with God's help, anything is possible. Just try to get a feeling for your experience with people
on these protocols. Okay, so it really depends on, you know, a couple of things. Well, first of all,
to come into the, I'm considering the way to start chemo, ask my ecologist if she could order a
CT scan in a month or two to see if there's any changes either way. Most likely the answer to that
question from your ecologist is going to be no because there are some qualifications to be
considered in whether your insurance will pay for another CT scan. If you're not doing the therapy
that is recommended, most likely your insurance will not approve another CT scan. So that's probably
not an option. That's probably going to be what the ecologist would say plus the ecologist would have
a bias in that. Well, if you're not going to do what I'm telling you to do, I'm not going to order
CT scan. They may be totally okay with ordering blood work for you as long as your comment to them was
I may want to wait on the chemo. Could I continue to get blood work while I'm in the decision-making
process? I'm not saying no, but I'm just postponing this. They may be open to continue to do blood
work and to see you and do exams and such. But I don't know about getting, you know, an expensive
test like a CT scan whether they'd be open to that and I highly doubt if your insurance would be
open to that. Is it unrealistic to expect that any nutritional rife, any alternative protocol
would show improvement in one or two months? No, it's not unrealistic. Is it probable? Maybe it partly
depends on the rate that the cancer is growing and if you just were diagnosed with cancer
and let's say it's staged for, it's metastasized to multiple organs, we don't know the rate that
means the speed of growth. So if it's growing very rapidly, sometimes you need to do some chemo to not
clean this down. It would be a little different story if a person and I don't remember who asked
this question what their cancer is, but let's pretend it's a couple scenarios so we can get a better
example. If a woman had a lump in her breast and she palpated that lump and felt there was something
wrong and finally went in after several months of, this is not getting any better,
got a mammogram, went through a diagnostic procedure and she was diagnosed with breast cancer.
The lump was the size of a grape and the oncologist told her we need to do chemotherapy right away to
shrink it and then we're going to do surgery. That's typical scenario with a lump in the breast
and the woman said, is it unrealistic for me to do a natural protocol, whatever that consists of
and to see improvement in one or two months, I would say that's not unrealistic because we know
the cancer is so far just contained in one spot. You just noticed it six months ago, you have a lump
whatever size it is and it hasn't changed dramatically over the time that you've noticed it.
Is it realistic to give it 30 to 60 days to see if we can stop the growth of it? I think that's
very realistic. But if a different scenario was the woman had a lump in her breast, she went in and
had a biopsy, it was positive for cancer and she had an MRI and she had metastasis to the lungs,
metastasis to the bone and is that going to be the same scenario? Well, no because it's further
down this down stage and is it unrealistic to see? Is it unrealistic to expect that a nutritional
protocol is going to see improvement? I wouldn't say it's not realistic. Everything's possible. We've
seen miraculous changes in people, but the probability is lower. If a person is in a later stage
cancer, the probability goes down. Again, this is so dependent on every case. If the person was given
chemotherapy regimen that was basically not curative, meaning we're going to just do chemo because
that's all we got to do. Your stage 4, we don't have anything else. If that's really what's being offered,
then I would say that it's not that you're necessarily expecting giant changes but you're really
trying to have a protocol that's going to give you a much longer life and hopefully be curative
but have no side effects. I don't see any problem with post-pony things. As long as you stay on top of
subjective findings, as my pain gotten worse, objective findings, can I monitor this with different
blood work? You could get lots of clues in blood work whether your cancer is growing or not.
Let's say you look at a CBC with differential. If you have an increase
prevalence of anemia, it's going to be a sign that the cancer is growing. That's a possibility.
It increases in your alkaline phosphatase. It increases in your calcium. That's all signs
that your cancer is growing. If you have positive tumor marker tests that are showing up
and you do a subsequent test in two weeks and you're doing blood work every two weeks and
your tumor markers are double lead. That's a sign that we need to use something else to try to knock
this down. The alternative perspective approach is not stealthful enough to knock this down on
its own. There are ways to monitor it, short of getting a CT stand which probably won't be approved.
You can do blood work on a very regular basis. I've had people start when we're doing blood work weekly.
We want to keep a close eye on this. Even if they're oncologists won't order that, we can order
that blood work. It's not super expensive, like a $5,000 CT stand and we can order that and keep
an eye on it and make sure we're not going severely in the wrong direction. Either way, I would always
be super kind to my oncologists. Be very thankful to them. Even if you prayed about this and prayed
about this and you don't feel peace about moving forward with chemotherapy, I would still tell them
that exactly what is going on honestly. I'm praying about this and I don't feel peace about moving
forward. It doesn't mean I'm saying no, I'm just saying no for right now. I really appreciate you
and I want to keep a relationship with you. That would be my recommendation and how you talk to
an oncologist. If they get angry and they, you know, they're the my way or the highway type personality,
then just go to a different oncologist. You'll find somebody who will work with you however you want
to be worked with and understands your case and your dilemma and your spirituality in this and your
decision making process. So we just want to keep an eye on it. So if a person comes to me and they
have stage 4 cancer, they're like, I don't want to do chemo, then we do want to keep an eye on things
close more closely. Hope that helps. Next question. I was going to ties into that again. How can I find out
if my cancer is getting better or not? I'm feeling really well but just want to know. Well again,
the best way to know if your cancer is improving or not is to compare apples to apples with a
test but just like that last question, if you had a CT scan to diagnose the cancer in the first place,
it's quite often you're not going to be eligible to get another CT scan because you made up doing
the therapy that the oncologist is asking you to do or you may not want to do another CT scan because
of the radiation involved. So you can't compare apples to apples. So let's say you could compare apples to
apples. That would be the best way to know objectively whether your problem is improved or not.
But there are other ways. So let's say I can't compare apples to apples for whatever reason.
Had a CT scan, don't want to do it again or not eligible to do it again, change my insurance, whatever.
Are there other ways? Yes, there's blood work to objectively look at things.
Remember, everything is just going to give you clues. So let's say I do blood work and I have
doing a tumor marker test and I show positive CA125 by tumor marker test and then subsequent
to a marker test to stay the same or it's going down. Those are good signs. If it doubled or tripled,
that's not a good sign. Even if you're feeling better, you go to look at subjective and objective
data. So I'm feeling really good. But my CA125 went from 42 to 260. The last time I did it was 42,
now it's 260. That's not good. So that's not good. So we do want to dig a little deeper. We may want
to do some other objective tests. We may want to find out what's going on.
But that's a my CA125 was 42 and now it's 42 again or no, it's 38 or no, it's 46.
You know, it's right around that same number. There's a margin of error in all these testing.
And I'd say, hey, had your feeling well, you're comparing that to subjective findings. And let's say
that was the only thing abnormal of your blood work that I'd say you're probably doing really well.
So it's we just keep monitoring. So we use whatever objective data we can to to to find out with,
you know, to whatever degree you're comfortable in going. I don't want to do another MRI. I don't
want to do another PET scan. Okay. Well, let's do blood work. Could you would you do that? Yes,
I'll do that. And we'll use that as our objective data to give us the clues that we need to know
whether you're getting worse or getting better. And you compare that to it's your subjective data.
I'm feeling we're real well. You know, I'm there's lots of clues just in a CDC with differential
in a in a comprehensive metabolic profile at a tumor marker panel that could give us objective
data that could, you know, tell us which way we're going. So relatively inexpensive for a few hundred
dollars, we could kind of get a good picture of what's going on and how we're doing. Like I said,
if just to the CBC with differential, if I had a normal CBC, you know, three months ago,
and I want to know how I cancers do it, but I don't want to do anything other than a blood work.
And now by CBC shows, you know, an anemia, as well as, you know, other things on a cup
ahead of a metabolic profile or a tumor marker panel, that would tell us that we're not going to
the right direction. And we either, we need to tweak your protocol, we need to change things,
we need to do a other cheek swab test, we need to consider speaking to an ecologist, we need to do
something different if our objective data and or subjective data is going the wrong direction.
Next question. Can any of the toxicity labs, if we want to retest, be covered by insurance?
No, so none of the like the mosaic or toxicity labs or parasite labs or
any of the functional medicine labs are never going to be covered by insurance. So,
but I'm really good at insurance, I have Medicare plus blah, blah, blah, is still not going to be
covered. It's not going to be covered. Now, if you have like Samaritan's ministries, which technically
is a insurance, we've had people get that cover, it covered under that, but that's pretty much
the only one. So, and that is, you still have to pay for it and then you submit it and hope they cover it,
and so that's not a for sure thing, but insurance is not going to cover any of the other functional
labs. Now, insurance may cover a CBC with the pharyngeal and a cover hits a metabolic panel and a
tumor marker panel if it's ordered by your primary practitioner, but many times you go into the
primary practitioner and you say this is what I want and they order something completely different.
But it's worth a shot. I mean, if you could get your Medicare to cover some of those labs,
and that's just money in your pocket, you paid for it in the first place, I think you should try
to do that. It also presupposes that you have a medical doctor that you have a relationship with.
So, I always try to get people, encourage people to seek that out if they can,
so that they can get, so we can get regular labs. It would be the functional medicine labs,
but regular labs covered and done on a regular basis. I just think the more frequently that we can
do those labs, the more objective data that we have to formulate a working
gene, diagnostic criteria of how to move forward and where you're at and how we're progressing.
So, the more data we have, the better. What would cause lack of energy? My fatigue has been
overwhelming lately. So, it changed in energy levels, an increase in fatigue.
If it's some sudden, and it improves relatively quickly, let's say I just was exhausted
last week for about three days. I just felt like I needed to take a nap during the day. I don't know
what was wrong with it. It's just very odd, but I don't feel that anymore. Then what was the cause
of that? Well, it was probably nothing pathological, meaning long-term pathological. Could have
had a virus. Could have had some sort of other infection, something like that. Could have had some
adrenal fatigue from something. That's what you think of for intermittent lack of energy.
But what a person has like all of a sudden they have fatigue more than usual and they start
making the comments to themselves like, what is wrong with me? I just feel like I need to take a nap.
I'm just tired. It'll feel like I have the energy that I used to and this is more
long-standing and it's not going away. Then that's where blood work comes in. So, looking at blood
work, you know, you personally you look at for this would be a CBC with a differential because
that would, if you had an elevated white blood cell count, then it could be a chronic infection or
a suppressed white blood cell count with a diagnosis of cancer. Could still be an indication of a chronic
viral infection. But the biggest thing you look at is the red blood cell markers and whether a
person has anemia. So, the biggest thing you want to look at with the person with a diagnosis of
cancer is, you know, do they have anemia as well? Now, many people come to me and we get started
on care and they already have anemia. Well, we want to try to get the blood built up by helping get
the person built up and not just, you know, iron and the mix. That's typical thing that you take more
if I have anemia that I need to start taking iron. Well, not all anemias are iron deficiency anemias.
But most anemias of chronic disease be the anemias caused from cancer are iron deficiency anemias
and we would look at the blood work, depending on all those other markers, the RDW, the
total play that percentage and all those things. Those other things in the CBC would help us
determine what type of anemia could it be a B12 anemia? Could it be a B6 anemia? Could it be a
folate anemia? But anemia of a chronic disease anemia that's associated with cancer is almost always
going to be an iron deficiency anemia because the cancer is gobbling up iron. And that's leaving the
person in a state of anemia. A mild anemia is going to still cause a person to have fatigue. Even if
if your red blood cell count is no more, but your hemoglobin and hematocrit are low, it could give
a person a relative state of fatigue. And the greater the about the greater degree of anemia is going
to be the greater degree of fatigue. And we need to address that. We need to deal with that. So
what would be the cause of lack of energy if it's long-standing and getting worse? We want to get
a blood work done. CBC with differential, comprehensive metabolic panel, and look at our markers and see
if things are going in a direction that we don't want to go. Because like I said, same thing about
the question of how do I know if I'm getting better or not, or how do I know if I'm getting worse or
not? Would be, let's say I had blood work three months ago, everything was normal, pretend that now I
do blood work, and now I have anemia. And everything three months ago wasn't even at the end of anemia. So
this is my red blood cell count, my hemoglobin, my hematocrit, and other numbers are often by CBC.
That's not a good thing. We need to address that. So that's why getting regular blood work
can be a good idea. Okay, next question. When you do another Cheekswob test and you tell us to stop
certain supplements, should we stop right away or should we finish the bottle? Also, how do you come up
with that conclusion? So first of all, how we come up with the conclusion of the Cheekswob test?
Literally, I'm prayed over your Cheekswob and testing with kitesology to know what is going to be
the right thing to do and what to stop and what to continue and the dosage and all this kind of
stops. So I'm testing everything on your Cheekswob, it takes a while. So should you stop something
right away if it says stop? So yes, if it says stop, just stop it. Sometimes I'll write phase off.
That means just finish the bottle. And always if you have a question, just call or ask a question
on the Zoom call. So that's what you're doing. Whoever asks this question, thank you. So if it says
just phase off, just just finish what you have and then you stop. If it says stop, then stop it.
Just you don't need that anymore. You're just going to stop that. Or if it says you were taking
four a day and it says drop to two a day, drop to two a day, right away, pretty simple instructions with
that. I think that's the answer to that question. My husband and I are composting our poo at our
homestead. After two years, our first batch looks like a really good product. But we are wondered if
it's safe to use in the garden since my husband does not eat organic to the microorganisms in the
compost. Take care of any toxins, chemicals from non-organic processed foods.
Well, first of all, even if you are taking compost from your, let's say you have livestock and let's
say you are feeding organic chicken feed to your chickens. Well, your chickens, if you are free
ranging your chickens in the summer, they're eating your grass, which is not sprayed with any toxins
and if that's going to be a much more organic product, right? But let's say you're getting compost
for your garden from the neighbor who has cows and they're not feeding their cows organic and
they're spraying their fields for weeds, which I'm not sure that anybody that's pasturing cattle
is spraying their fields for weeds. But let's pretend they're feeding, well, they're feeding grains,
so let's say it's not grass-fed and they're not grass-fed and they're feeding GMO corn,
which for sure cattle would be eating and you're taking that cattle manure composted and
putting it on your garden. Are you getting roamed up in that garden? Yeah, the danger is real. Yes,
you are. So you just have to be aware of that, the danger is real. Now, would I personally in my garden
use human feces, human excrement composted in my garden? No, I wouldn't. Could you put it elsewhere
in your yard? You know, to fertilize a field that maybe your cattle are on or something like that?
I don't see any harm in that. I don't know if any harm in that. Is there are there microorganisms in the
compost that are taking care of toxins, chemicals from non-organic processed foods? No, it depends on
the toxin itself. Microorganisms will take care of certain things and not other things. For instance,
use an example of very widely used broadleaf herbicide abbreviated 240. So why does the golf course
have any weeds on it? Because they're spraying 240 like crazy. Why does the park that you take your
kids go and play on not have any dandelions? Because they're sprayed 240. Maybe that is off
in its golf course, but they're sprayed 240 on it. 240 is the most commonly used herbicide in
home herbicide remedies. Like if you have, it can be used as a granular, it can be used as a spray,
it's in certain things. You'd have to read the ingredients on it. But if you're putting some,
you're going to lose and you're buying a fertilizer slash herbicide for your yard and putting that on
pretty much guarantee it's got 240. Now the pros and cons of 240, pros are it's going to kill weeds,
it's going to kill dandelions. You're not going to be dandelions in your yard.
The the negative is it's highly toxic, highly toxic, maybe even more toxic than Roundup glyphosate.
But one positive of 240 is that the soil has microorganisms in it that break it down. It's got a half
life of I think like 10 days or something like that in the soil by soil microorganisms. Now if you
took that that herbicide and you just ate it, that's how you just consumed 240. You don't have
those microorganisms to break it down, but they are in the soil. So you could have toxicity in
matter of fact that talks detect tests for 240. So you could have elevated the levels of 240
because you ate a plant that was contaminated with 240, meaning it was sprayed more recently than,
a month and a half ago because it would be pretty much all gone within maybe a couple of months.
But let's say you ate that plant that was sprayed with 240. Now it's in your body. Now it's
got a half life of like a million years. It's not going to be broken down by your microorganisms. You
have to detoxify it. So are there microorganisms in that compost that are going to break down some
toxins like 240? I don't know. Glyphosate, on the other hand, doesn't have microorganisms that break it
down. And that's the negative of glyphosate. It is also toxic and can be cancer-causing,
but it's more prevalent in certain crops. So it's more ubiquitous and it's more toxic as far as
you're just never going to break that down in your body either. It doesn't break down in the soil.
So that's why to be listed as organic, you have to let your soil sit for five years and get
retested because it takes that lung for to break down glyphosate. So what I use compost from
human excrement on my garden personally, I wouldn't. I don't know that it's been researched enough
to know that. I just wouldn't do that. Next question is this Kirkland brand mixed seed butter,
a good substitute for peanut butter. So Kirkland brand is Costco's brand. I looked at that and it
seemed like it was good. That would be a good seed butter substitute for peanut butter. The only
thing I couldn't see on that I didn't know what was organic if anything was organic. So you do want
to take that into consideration too, is looking for our organic product. Okay, some questions from
the chat and if you want to verbalize a question, remember to unmute yourself. First question. My
ferritin is 32. I was reading that body is in survival mode and sacrifices hair and others to keep
heart working and blood oxygenated. What are your thoughts? I heard total is 110 hemoglobin within range.
Your ferritin of 32 is within, considered within normal range. And would you look at
ferritin levels? You really want to look as if it's elevated. Now if a person has edibia,
so their hemoglobin is low, their red blood cell can be low as well. But what are the best
clues that you pick up of ferritin is if it's elevated. So an elevated ferritin is going to
indicate whether the person maybe is overdosed on iron because they heard iron is good for you,
so they're taking iron. But most commonly it's due to inflammation. So if a person's ferritin is
elevated, the rule of thumb is they cannot take iron. You're just causing a gross inflammation and
it can be because of the iron. If your iron is 110, your hemoglobin is in range. I want to look at
everything together as far as your CBC to get a better understanding of what's going on. So
next question. What do you think of consuming apricot seeds? So apricot seeds are a way to get
B17. Now the pros and cons of taking apricot seeds. The pros is you're getting it as a whole food
product because you're getting the B17 and the B15 that is in the apricot seeds as a quote-unquote
therapy. The negative is that they taste horrible and you really have to eat like 30 of them to
get the dose that's going to be really helpful for cancer. Now I don't remember your cheek swab
test and what came up on your cheek swab test. But again, I test for B17. And if that didn't come up,
I don't know that again, it's the same thing. I mean, you could take a zillion things. So if that's
what you, if that's what you're being led to do, then I'm not telling you not to. But you know,
you don't want to be overwhelmed in your body. Also remember that B17, you have to keep an eye on
your liver markers if you're going to be taking B17. So we've got to keep an eye on that.
And if you're taking apricot seeds that calls into that category, all I ask you is if anybody,
I'm going to put this out to everybody, not just the person asking this question. If you're taking
things beyond what I recommended on your cheek swab, you're going to do it. God's lady, you do. But by
all means, can you please let me know so that we can get it in your file because I don't want to
like recheck your cheek swab in two months and ask you, can you send me a list of everything you're
taking. And then you send me a list. This just happened a couple months ago. The person I haven't
heard from for over a year. And I asked them to send me a list of what they're taking. And they're
taking several things that a cancer patient should not be taking. It could cause a cancer to grow. So
please just let me know. God led me to take this. And I feel led to take this. And if I, if it's a good
thing for cancer like apricot seeds, you might not hear from me. But if you say God just led me to take
these methylated vitamins and because my sister said it's really helped her with her anxiety. So
I started taking these. Okay, I'm going to reach out to you and say I don't think that's a good idea.
And I'll give you the reason. So it's just let me know. So you're so you're so you're
sure you're not taking something that I don't think you should take. So the caveat with apricot
seeds, if you're going to take apricot seeds and you feel led to take those apricot seeds,
we've got to make sure we're checking your comprehensive metabolic panel because it can
affect your AST, ALT and alkaline phosphates. Next question, do you see any value in a daily shot
with the ingredients of juice of one organic lemon, one tablespoon, good olive oil, one
teaspoon black seed oil. I don't see any problem with that. The only the only caveat to that
would be you're you're taking a tablespoon of olive oil. Do you? If the person doesn't have a
gallbladder that could be an issue. But if they have a gallbladder that could help their gallbladder
flush, so that could actually be helpful. I don't see any problem with that at all. So there's no
negatives to that. Do I know of a good olive oil? Well, you can go back and forth on all sorts of
different philosophies of what good olive oil is and that that good olive oil and
and it's just really hard to to kind of wade through that that muck. I would just try to buy an
organic olive oil and it's always good to try to buy one that's from a single source. If you look
on the back and it says product of Italy, then you know it's coming from Italy. If it says
product of Italy, Spain and Portugal, then it's a mixed olive oil that they may be cutting it with
cheaper versions. So you'll want it to be a single source olive oil. There's I know there's some
places in all of vineyards in California where you can buy olive oil straight from them. It's coming
from one vineyard and I think you can get that from places in Italy too. That's what I would,
you know, at least been taught to look for it makes sense to me. Any other questions? Get
if you want to verbalize something just unmute yourself. Something else? When once?
Well thanks for being on the call. Just a reminder for everybody to be prayed for everybody else
and I think that's just what we're called to do to be prayed for one another. So just a reminder and
know that we're praying for you. If you have any specific prayer requests that are out of the ordinary
other than for your healing and for wisdom and your decision making process, that's what I pray for
or anything for all of you. But if you have any specific prayer requests don't feel bad about,
you know, please do email info at cuttersclinic.com. I feel like that's a big part of our ministry
is to be prayed for you. So God bless you. We'll see you guys next week and have a blessed week.